c'est le sprint à quelques heures de
l'ouverture on installe les nouveaux
lampadaires en a juste les caniveaux
voici donc le nouveau look de la rue
sainte catherine ouest trottoirs élargis
nouveau mobilier urbain nouveaux arbres
rues pavées il y aura désormais une
seule voie de circulation et plus aucun
stationnement
moi je trouve ça c'est magnifique
c'était joli ça vaut la peine d'investir
je suis content mais pas plus que ça
sera pas facile pour les autos possède
déjà deux manches pleines de sang mêlé
cônes sont encore là pour longtemps
le tronçon qui ouvre samedi celui entre
de bleury et robert bourassa est le seul
qui ait terminé toutes les autres phases
jusqu'à la toiture se feront
graduellement jusqu'en 2028
elles incluront le nouveau square
phillips qui sera terminé dans deux ans
et la nouvelle rue mcgill college déjà
en travaux pour leur m dont le
réaménagement sera terminée fin 2026
howe est un peu chaotique mais bon à
montréal on te prêtes-tu oscille de se
promener piste un peu partout ont trouvé
ce que c'était mal organisé
mais avec le temps je crois qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de conversations à l'internet
ils y ont appris des erreurs qui ont
appliqué
puis vers la fin jusqu'à aujourd'hui je
trouve que ça a été beaucoup mieux
à l'angle mansfield les travaux ont deux
ans de retard dit le propriétaire du
sport expert juste à côté
c'est extrêmement difficile et de rémy
n'acceptant que moi on ne doit être
agile quant à l'octroi des contrats
justement pour éviter des dépassements
de coûts tous les efforts seront faits
en aménagement temporaire en mesure de
mitigation les commerçants l'espère s'il
aime la nouvelle rue sainte catherine
il espère avant tout survivre à ces
travaux
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
n'ont rien